So, the Parker Solar Probe is about to launch
and have its first solar flyby in November.
We have plenty of fuel to do
another three, four, five years of mission.
But, after that time the thrusters will burn out and ultimately it will become a sungrazing comet
And end its life melting in the solar corona.
Whenever you look at something far away
you're really seeing the light
which is summed up over all the path of
everything that comes to you.
Even observing the solar corona from afar you might ask, "why do we have to go with a solar probe?"
We can see the corona during eclipses.
We know how to build coronagraphs.
Well, the problem is that we can't really
measure the magnetic field there.
And the observations that we make are really a sum of the whole gas that exists between us and infinity.
It's not a local measurement.  That's why we need to go.
The energy deposition occurs in bursts-- it's
not a continuous flow.
These bursts are equivalent to millions of hydrogen
bombs exploding per hour in the solar corona.
That's what we're trying to understand.
Even the defense departments of various nations in the world are beginning to deploy spacecraft whose
role is to monitor this, what we call space weather.
Parker Solar Probe has a different goal. It wants
to go in to understand the basis.
What does space weather depend on.
So, Parker Solar Probe is going to start sending
data back in bursts
because we can only send data back from the probe
when it's closer to Earth. When this data
comes down, we have already set up a
series of working groups for people
trying to study specific problems
specific data sets. And, of course, the
students that we have here at UCLA will
be involved in all aspects of this.